good morning John so if you listen to
delete this which I'm just gonna assume
that you do you know about a thing that
I call Twitter holes basically it's a
quote tweet of someone's quote tweet of
someone's quote tweet and they all have
the same format and you can go down and
down and down deeper and deeper and
deeper into the hole until eventually
you like to actually arrive at like the
progenitor tweet hole tweet which is
pretty cool I know you know nothing
about this because you're not on social
media and that was just a part of the
popularization of a Twitter hole and I
know this because of my replies right
now which we'll just call the five jobs
Twitter hole you just list five jobs
you've had and then ask what about you
successful Twitter things are
interesting to me because they give me a
chance to like ask the question like
what do we find rewarding about this
what service is being provided why do
people add to a Twitter hole well in
this case I think a lot of the service
is being given a chance an opportunity
an excuse to talk about yourself which
we all like to do but also there's
another service here a chance to see
what other jobs people have had a little
bit of a glimpse though an incomplete
one into the paths that life has taken
people on and look I don't love that
paid labor is at the moment at least one
of the most important things that we use
to define ourselves but that's the
situation we're in work is very commonly
a huge part of people's lives and of
their identities this gives people a
chance to like write a very quick and
easy little mini biography of themselves
reflect on the past and it gives
everyone else a glimpse into like what
might have been or what might still be I
just don't think it does a good job of
that because it's like the most
simplified version of this possible John
you may not have noticed this because
I'm not sure I did but back in 2007 I
started being done with a camcorder and
then over the course of a number of
years became the CEO of at one point or
another four different companies and
that's if you don't include 2d glasses I
don't really know how this happened I
was too busy at the time to pay
attention I've had a bunch of jobs like
research assistant Quality Control
chemists Walmart associate production
assistant various things but my first
office job was boss I don't like to talk
about this too much because a lot of my
employees watch my videos but I had no
idea what the Frick I was doing I didn't
have time to figure it out all I could
do was like pay attention to how like
the audience was doing how the
financials were doing
how the team was doing and choose on any
given day which of those things was
gonna be the most important thing to me
based on nothing certainly wasn't gonna
go to business school I didn't have time
for that I also don't know how
applicable it even would have been to my
work but it's still important to think
about and understand this weird
structure that is imaginary and yet also
is like the foundation of a lot of how
value gets created by humans today in my
office we've been working on like a
business crash course that isn't
Business School it's what we're calling
soft skills we've been working on it for
a few months and people keep like
walking into meetings after working on
one of these videos and saying like why
didn't anyone explain this to me which
is kind of funny because like it's
exactly what we're trying to do it's
just that we had to be the ones to do it
I guess how to build trust emotional
influence communication negotiation job
hunting interviews all kinds of stuff
there's lots more on the way it's gonna
be a bigger part of the average person's
life than like chemistry though I still
think you should learn chemistry it's
great but also we should learn about
this stuff I am a CEO and I'm learning
stuff with every episode which is
something that is like at once a little
embarrassing but also something that I'm
kind of proud of because no matter what
job you're on there's a lot to learn and
maybe more than you're gonna learn from
a Twitter hole and also the whole series
together is a lot shorter than endgame
John I'll see you on Tuesday